hey guys how's it going happy animal
launch day today we are going to be
unboxing the new Apple watch series -
this is the ceramic version this is one
of the newest ones that they announced
and I'm extremely excited to open it and
yes this is an actual unboxing so please
just don't worry this is this is small
fake oh man this is significantly
heavier than I thought it was gonna be
I'm excited to see the packaging I have
no idea I haven't watched any other
unboxings I know nothing about what's in
here I just can't believe all heavy this
is okay this is what we came for
are you ready my heart skipped to be lot
of boxes this is a very very nice box I
will definitely be using this to put
something and I'm not sure what this is
it
it was quite deceiving sign side the box
was just this little guy sitting on top
of some items wool got a tiny little
basic brick
[Music]
oh wow comes with one to the Apple watch
dock chargers these things are awesome
if you have an Apple watch I recommend
getting one of these if you don't have
one already because this just uses a
lightning cable so you don't have to
actually bring this cable along you just
have to bring this I'm not sure if
that's easier or more difficult but I
love having this dock it's such a great
addition and I'm super glad that they
did include this with this version I'm
not sure which are the ones they include
it with so it comes with the charging
dock and two different cables the Apple
watch little disk charger that's what
they're calling it and it's like the
size of a quarter some paperwork see if
this oh and of course don't make the
mistake that a lot of people have done
they don't realize that the other band
is inside of this folder and this time
they put the small version usually they
put the larger side on here so I
definitely need to swap that out because
I do use the smaller one what if this
will come out it won't I really wanted
to use this box to put things in let's
open up the main attraction
oh look at you Wow the white looks so
fresh so freakin fresh
[Music]
one of the highlights for the keynote
from me talking about the Apple watch to
was talking about how they made at the
speaker also be water-resistant so the
speaker actually vibrates and forces the
water out so that there won't be any
water inside of it like this little
button is all white let's try it on
I'm also left-handed so eyewear watches
on the right so after I set it up I'm
gonna have to swap it this way so that
the it is actually upside down because a
little crown will be here and then I end
up having to also slope this
[Music]
Wow looks nice so here it is in
comparison to the Apple watch stainless
steel version this is the first version
this is the Apple watch series - it's a
really very it's a beautiful device
this thing is so scratched Wow I've
destroyed this this one also went
through a few wash cycles small this is
booting up I shouldn't take a second to
say I'm sorry to anyone who was upset
with my iphone 7 unboxing to be fair
everything that I said in that video I
hundred percent will be saying almost
the exact same thing if the phone was in
my hand there has been an update and I
will have it by Monday so I'm super
excited that I'll actually be able to do
an unboxing let me know the comments if
any of you guys have gotten your watches
or your iPhone 7 or your iPhone 7 plus
or if you're like I don't have either
and I don't what there's a whole new
face gallery figure guys haven't seen
those yet whoa
scandalous click Perrineau watch and
please work yes my watches parody it's
so sad to see my rose gold one on there
that shattered sort of the features that
I'm most excited about for this Apple
watch especially if you guys are into
fitness or any type of fitness tracking
is this has a GPS integrated into it
whereas the previous versions did not so
you had to have your phone to be able to
use the GPS this is now able to track
your runs it also is water resistant up
to 50 meters so if you're into swimming
it will be able to track those types of
things as well although I have tested
the previous version and it was quite
water resistant in a nice laundry cycle
so hopefully that doesn't happen
this one let me know what you guys think
of the latest Apple releases and this
again is the ceramic Apple watch edition
series - baby I look forward to trying
it out and I'm sure I'll have some
follow-up videos and follow-up vlogs
here in the next few days after I get a
chance to try it out and really test it
to the limits and my tested to the
limits I probably won't be doing much of
anything but it can fitness track me
playing call of duty thank you guys so
much for watching I will see you in the
next video when I apologize again to
anybody who was upset with the iPhone 7
video I will be getting it on Monday so
I'm really really looking forward to
that so I'll be doing a full unboxing
and if you guys have been worried about
your shipping dates go check those Apple
orders because they did update a bunch
of them today and they're shipping early
so I'm excited you guys should be
excited and I'm gonna go put my uh my
watch on May felissa setup so see you
guys soon it's the iPhone 7 plus and
what's cool about this is it's a black
box and this is super rare so the jet
black version is the only one that comes
in this black box so it's pretty cool
I'm gonna take a look at it before we
open it up yeah
pretty incredible